former president Donald Trump has been
informed that he's the target of a
criminal investigation this is according
to several media reports that a letter
has been sent to his lawyers who met
with the Department of Justice earlier
in the week such a step is made when uh
charging is imminent and when it's
believed that there is substantial
evidence that would justify a
prosecution now this all stems from the
fact that dozens of documents were found
at Trump's Mario Lago estate many of
them classified and also allegations
that he orchestrated a scheme to conceal
these documents from authorities now
there has been a grand jury impaneled in
Washington which has been investigating
the matter and recently a second grand
jury was impaneled in Florida thus
indicating that Federal processes may
take place in South Florida because it's
at the Mar-A-Lago estate where the cry
times allegedly took place now this
indication to that the special
prosecutor investigating the matter Jack
Smith is very close to a charging
decision